- [Mark] All right, Andrea.
Andrea, where are you from originally,
where'd you grow up?
- [Andrea] Kansas City, Missouri.
A small town called Pleasant Valley,
it's a suburb.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You grow up with both parents, one parent?
- [Andrea] I started with both parents,
then they got a divorce and
I mostly grew up with my mom.
- [Mark] Got it.
And, how was your childhood?
- [Andrea] Crappy. I didn't
have a happy childhood.
- [Mark] What happened,
what made it unhappy?
- [Andrea] Abused by most
of my peers in childhood,
most of my children peers,
I've been abused in my home
life, too, by my father,
that's why my parents got a divorce.
- [Mark] Sexually abused?
- [Andrea] Yes, yeah.
- [Mark] At what age?
- [Andrea] Five and six years old.
- [Mark] And what kind
of stuff would happen?
- [Andrea] Oral sex, and
a finger in my vagina.
- [Mark] Really?
- [Andrea] Yeah.
- [Mark] From your dad?
- [Andrea] Right.
- [Mark] Wow. And, so,
what happened to your life
as you got older? High school,
what kind of kid were you in high school?
- [Andrea] I grew right
along with my mother,
but I really had very few friends and I
was very lonely. I grew up very lonely.
I've had to make sure I've
had a social life in my
adult life.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- [Andrea] I've had a
much happier social life
in my adult life.
- [Mark] Oh, I see. And how long have you
been down here on the street? On Skid Row?
- [Andrea] I've been down here
since December 23rd, 2002.
- [Mark] So you've been here
for almost twenty years?
- [Andrea] Yeah, pretty much.
- [Mark] And do you have kids of your own,
or anything like that?
- [Andrea] I have a grown
son and that's ever light.
- [Mark] And did you raise him?
- [Andrea] No, my parents raised him.
- [Mark] And, so what is
your drug here on the street?
You mention spice is what you?
- [Andrea] Yeah, I love
doing lemon beer and spice.
- [Mark] Spice. What
does spice do for you?
- [Andrea] Like marijuana, extra strength.
- [Mark] Yeah. Um..
- [Andrea] And if I get
bit by things like bedbugs,
they die immediately.
- [Mark] (laughs) And where
do you sleep at night?
- [Andrea] I live over here,
I have indoor residence
but no toilet or shower.
Over here on Town Avenue.
- [Mark] So you actually have a room?
- [Andrea] Yeah, I have a
room but no toilet or shower.
- [Mark] Okay, but you have a bed then?
- [Andrea] Yes.
- [Mark] That's nice, its something.
- [Andrea] Yeah. I'm happy I have a place
indoors.
- [Mark] Yeah, and what
do you, uh, do for money?
- [Andrea] I'm on SSI.
- [Mark] Okay. What kind
of, do you have contact
with your mom still?
Or anything like that?
- [Andrea] No, my mom passed away.
- [Mark] So you're kind
of on your own now.
- [Andrea] My mom passed away
in 2005. Yeah, pretty much.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
- [Andrea] I have a
few friends, no family.
And I'm happy with that.
- [Mark] Yeah. How do you
spend your days? What do
you do?
- [Andrea] Ehh. That time
I do special activities.
I like to read my Bible.
- [Mark] How often do you uh, smoke spice?
- [Andrea] Everyday.
- [Mark] Everyday. Was
that the uh, what was the
first drug you tried.
- [Andrea] I drank alcohol.
- [Mark] Alcohol.
- [Andrea] Wait a minute.
No, its cigarettes. Tobacco
in there. Tobacco is
considered a drug right?
- [Mark] Yeah, I guess
so. Have you, uh, tried
cocaine or heroin or crystal meth?
- [Andrea] In my arm,
crystal meth. I have tried
cocaine before, it was along time ago
when I lived in Florida.
- [Mark] Mm mm.
- [Andrea] Uh huh. I'm not
talking about crack, roll call.
- [Andrea] (wheezing)
- [Andrea] I smoke marijuana in fact.
- [Mark] All right, darling.
Well thank you so much.
- [Andrea] (not audible) (wheezing)
- [Mark] Well, Andrea, thank
you so much talking to me.
- [Andrea] Yeah.
- [Mark] And good luck
with everything out there.
- [Andrea] Oh, yes sir.